People think they know the story.
They think it's a story about one
man. But when you pull back the
curtain, it's actually about so much
more.
A recent Netflix documentary series
called "Madoff: The Monster of
Wall Street" by Emmy Award winning
filmmaker Joe Berlinger tells the
story of the largest
Ponzi scheme in history.
How could he fool so many people
for so long?
What happened was so avoidable
and so many people enabled it to
happen because of greed.
The film's other villain is the
Securities and Exchange Commission,
which received complaints about
Madoff starting in the early 1990s,
and yet not only failed to catch
him, but helped enable his
fraud.
During one investigation, all
SEC investigators had to do
was check the routing number to
verify a trade had actually
occurred—which it hadn't, of course,
because all of Madoff's trades
were fake.
You could have shut Madoff down in
one half hour by just following
up on one of his allegations that
they were not conducting trades.
If you are the watchdog, you have
totally and thoroughly failed in
your mission.
Don't you get it?
The Netflix series acknowledges that
the SEC is complicit in
Madoff's scam and that he could
have been caught if one investigator
assigned to the case had done about
30 minutes of checking.
They asked the question, they got
the information, they got the
account number, but they never made
the phone call.
Inconceivable, and I never
got an answer
that made any sense, to be honest,
from the people that we
questioned under oath in
depositions about
this particular point.
They forgot, they missed it,
but it just doesn't make any sense.
It also blames deregulation and
free market capitalism for making
the fraud possible.
The first episode sets the stage
with a speech by Ronald Reagan.
Government that is high taxes,
excessive spending and
overregulation, had
thrown a wrench in the works of our
free markets.
Our economic program for the next
four years, we're going to turn the
ball loose.
In episode three, journalist Diana
Henriques makes the connection
explicit.
Resources that had been
in New York City on Wall
Street's doorstep devoted
to white collar crime.
It's a fraud.
Were being steered away.
Were being funneled into
counterterrorism and
terrorism finance issues.
For the SEC, this was an
exacerbation of an existing problem
as a result of a deregulatory
campaign that began with the
election of Ronald Reagan in 1980.
In this present crisis,
government is not the solution to
our problem.
Government is the problem.
The laws that they could rely
on to pursue investigations
had been tightened and their budgets
had been cut and cut again.
And yet nothing in the film would
lead one to draw the conclusion that
the SEC needed a bigger budget
to catch Madoff.
In fact, outsiders were
sounding the alarm without access
to government funding or regulatory
muscle.
In 2001, Barron's journalist
Erin Arvedlund reported that
many Wall Street investors were
suspicious that Madoff was engaged
in foul play, and the SEC received
its first complaint that Madoff was
running an unregistered investment
company, offering 100%
safe investments, in 1992.
In 1999, a derivatives expert
named Harry Markopolos, who worked
at a competing firm, started to
alert the SEC that Madoff's
investment returns were virtually
impossible.
In 2005, Markopolos
sent the agency an infamous 25-page
memo explaining why the world's
largest hedge fund is a fraud.
The SEC opened an investigation in
2006 and then closed it the
following year because the
uncovered violations were remedied
and those violations were not so
serious as to warrant an enforcement
action.
We knew then that we had provided
enough red flags and
mathematical proofs
where they should have been able to
shut him down right then and
there.
Unfortunately, as they didn't
respond to my written submissions in
2000, 2001,
2005, 2007
and 2008, here we
are today.
So how is this tale of
epic failure on the part of a
government agency the fault of
deregulation?
Instead of making lazy allusions
to the evils of free market
capitalism, to better understand the
lessons of the Madoff saga, director
Joe Berlinger should have consulted
the work of the free market
economist George Stigler,
who won the Nobel Prize in part
for his work on regulatory
capture.
In a 1971 paper, "The Theory
of Economic Regulation," Stigler
argues that while many people
believe that regulation is
instituted primarily for the
protection and benefit of the
public, in fact, it
mainly serves the purposes of the
largest companies being regulated,
which form a symbiotic
relationship with their regulatory
overseers.
The essay focuses mainly on how
regulators help existing companies
by protecting them from competition,
but Stigler's theory can
also be used to better understand
the SEC's failure to catch
Madoff.
In a 1972 essay, Stigler
writes that the regulating agency
must eventually become the agency
of the regulated industry.
They need each other.
That's because the career lawyers at
the SEC making the decisions
have much more to gain personally
from having a positive relationship
with big industry players than
antagonizing them.
This is also what happened in the
case of Sam Bankman-Fried,
who was close with politicians
and regulators and actively lobbied
for regulation of the crypto
industry in a bid to
elbow out competitors—right
up to the moment that his crypto
exchange FTX collapsed
under the weight of its own alleged
fraud.
This cozy relationship between
industry and regulators helps
explain why the SEC
continually missed what was
right in front of them in the Madoff
case.
When Harry Markopolos was
trying to persuade the
SEC that
a gigantic, historically
huge Ponzi scheme was
being run at that very minute
by Bernie Madoff,
he was facing an enormous
challenge because the SCC
relied on Bernie Madoff
as a source of Wall Street wisdom.
He had a tremendous reputation
as being one of the real giants
of Wall Street, not only
for developments that
he helped launch, changes
in the industry that he helped
define, but
he also spent
a lot of time working with
the SEC and other government
agencies on panels and
assisting with
how to regulate business.
Madoff even spread the rumor
that he was being considered as
a future chairman of the SEC.
At one point, he tells them that
he is on the short list to become
the next head of the SEC.
And there's e-mail communication
between these two junior examiners
and their boss, where the boss says
to them, in joking, maybe you can be
Bernie's aides when he comes to take
over the SEC.
So they're awestruck to begin
with.
Can all of this depend on Ronald
Reagan, deregulation and the free
market?
One guy led you to
this pile of dung that is, that is
Bernie Madoff and stuck your nose in
it and you couldn't figure it out.
Is the SEC too cozy
with the industry?
Are they captive by this industry or
are they looking out for us, looking
out for the taxpayers?
The documentary also makes a strong
case that the SEC didn't just
fail to catch Madoff.
Investors were emboldened
by the agency's investigation of
Madoff and failure to find serious
violations such as this
man who gave Madoff the proceeds
from the sale of his small business.
The fact that the SEC found no
evidence of wrongdoing was,
to me, putting a stamp of approval
on Madoff.
So I sent
a wire for $900,000
to Madoff.
"That regulation is primarily
for the protection and benefit of
the public at large or some large
subclass of the public," Stigler
writes, is a commonly held view.
But it's not.
SEC investigators didn't want to be
overly combative with Madoff because
they thought doing so could hurt
their careers.
Regulation exists largely
to serve the interests of the people
being regulated.
The illusion of competent regulation
gave investors a false sense of
security that drove them to make
colossal mistakes.
Can the answer really be more
regulation?
What if Harry Markopolos's warnings
hadn't been filtered through the
SEC?
The average person is better
equipped to spot a con man than we
give him credit for.
But the myth that regulators are
primarily motivated to protect
the interests of the public causes
us to suspend our better judgment.
The big takeaway from "Madoff: The
Monster of Wall Street" is that
regulators unwittingly facilitated
his fraud just as they
helped Sam Bankman-Fried run his
alleged con.
As you watch the Netflix series,
think about how much more time
or power should we really
give them?
Are they helping us
or themselves?